an unusual follow-up after the extremely
successful Frozen movies not only a
third part is to come but also a podcast
with the title Disney's Frozen podcast
forces of nature Frozen 3 was announced
in February of this year and now a
12-part audio series is to follow with
forces of nature which will present us
with Further Adventures of the main
characters between the second and third
film in addition to the familiar
characters Elsa Anna Olaf and Kristoff
new characters will also make an
appearance in the audio series for
example Lord Wolfgang the nephew of the
Duke of wesselton and his pet magpies
Astrid and Magnus